non sai che stai per provare non te lo
posso garantire tu non lo sai
entra che convinto che devo fare ora un
passo anche io una volta ho detto sono
dentro cosa devo fare
ciao amico aia un attimo però io
controlli tecnici abbiamo pensato di
giocare contro gli altri
amico mio ascoltami gironi della
prossima da scott e scott e non una
serie 6 blocco è bello pietro ciao
pietro come stai bene ed esperti aspetta
fra questa non ci aggravate
hai fatto un casino amico o sopra visto
del geniale allora facciamo nei menu
propria vedere se riusciamo per
connetterci online con qualcuno non lo
so non credo che vedi liuc che è quello
di è così questo lo so io della madonna
come fortissimo
oddio no come mai allora attenzioni
costituto cosca ed ancora organtino
uccide per me sono io allora magari ha
fatto per me
ma che sergio secci gioco migliori di
questo incredibile no lui non ha fatto
niente non ha fatto il blu è veramente
la persona incazzata sono morto una
storia gran perdita occhio a pistone li
devo schivare i colpi o mio dio ecco la
parola data o addio addio l'ho ucciso io
sulla propria forma così cazzo stai
analitica però questa mappa ma cosa come
come ha vinto 9 non ho capito cosa di
ferro e mario dei problemi al cervello
veramente dei problemi
come è possibile ma causare una pistola
ma romania e anche tu non stai questo
bene tratto chi è che non so che quelli
sono proiettili che esplodono dopo che
gli spari dei provini vince muore con i
sottilissimi ai vince voli stupidissimi
non ha senso è arrivata con un picchio
il lungo divertiamo bravo pietro sono
morta dice eh sì o no
l'uomo ha [ __ ] tantissimo ma io me la
sono goduta in tutto questo noi dove lei
c'è madonna che porta gli ho dato
no c'è sei riuscito a schivare madonna è
una giorni ha ucciso allora come sono
partito io ho capito incastrato nel tubo
all'inizio ne ahia ahia fu uno contro
uno
no no no no no no da intimorire il
cugino grosso è disconnesso tanto
bisogno sono seduto solare
haier ha pubblicato anche pietrina amico
ciao amico
noi preferiamo fare i serpenti ma per
l'amor di gesù cosa diavolo per ha visto
luz marra rai cioè non mi sparano ti ha
truccato e cosa che ho fatto di marino
cosa per fatta
ora chiedi scusa per tutte le volte che
mi ha delusa pietro scusa pietra scusa
ma pietro e gay lo sanno tutti che tra
scherzi a parte con armi pietro
assistano si stanno chiedendo legate o
di aiuto 30 no e merluzzo è un pezzo
zone mamma mia che vi come via inglobati
tutti grazie blu che sei entrato mi ha
salvato la vita
non lo so pro domo di agliano a new york
verde è amico c'è un problema e scatto
scatto scatto uccidono e va bene certo
che tu e la mia se non la verità viene
anche mamma guarda basha
oddio forse acqua per me sarebbe stato
questo dove sarebbe stato avvisato
ciao amiche e pone come hanno fatto a
sopravvivere quelli io non ero ma poteva
ucciderti apprezza io non l'ho fatto
avviando la nostra
e vabbè cos'è quell'arma dai vieni qua
mi sono bloccato aiuto aiuto madonna
come lo spazio aiuto pietro tutto a
posto nostro passato anche delle armi
gli editori affetta la facciamo così
e sì perché fu sparassi a quei soldi la
renault non fare grazie no
[Musica]
pulisce aspettare solo questi dovrebbero
così come sta cazzo ho visto più che mai
vinto tutto l'altro ai mutui e sono
esplosivi che si è rimasta fatevi
chiamare aiuto
morto basta come i soldi la questione va
a pugni secolo dc anima l'altro 15 mesi
c'è quanto culo a quanto culo e bravura
oro a mille fabio volo da una mille
io avrei mai e che ricalcano parliamone
no no no no no dai a che ne è visto
gioco mi dà fastidio incredibile
buongiorno ragazzi oggi iniezioni di
spari la prima lezione uccidere
mamma mia scales al giallo problemino
onore anche su milano
ciao ragazzi divertitevi asili va bene
così è stato quelli saputo fare quello
che voleva potresti ahi ahi ahi oscura
il nuovo trovarla ok i due fuori potessi
fare pareggiando e mi dà fastidio è
basso per la potestà grande se molto
telefono dai marinai colpito va bene ma
quanto sei scarso no
maledetto penso di sterco fumante
beh io la prendo solo male mentre
giocava bene lui genio per numero uno ma
voglio bene amico tutta cose voglio bene
qual è la tua piattaforma questa è
quella del voglio bene amico a gesù
cristo
ora quanto si sente si sente rete non lo
tocchiamo neanche niente niente ma
vorrei che vince il blu in modo stupido
vuoi vedere come il punto del giallo
scommette hai visto da ho detto cosa è
sempre così appaiata alla madonna a
carlo caldo calmo sneaky peste ma come
dico pasteur questo è cattivo quanto
quanto è incazzato ma perché vince
sempre pietro non fa una sega non è
prontissimo il suo gioco
basta in scena che volo ha fatto il blu
no potuta sono morto
mammamia web player web player wow bella
mamma mia sono uscito con graziella no
non mi toccate vi denuncio
le gag possono rompere per esempio
quando gioco no
un'idea ma secondo sì la perdono può
vedere praticamente questa forma è molto
fare quanto pare si è incollato tutti
ragazzi dire che possiamo concludere vi
questo episodio di steve white è stato
bellissimo grazie per avermi
accompagnato in questa distruzione
stanno succedendo cose nel mentre faccio
questa auto
i ragazzi spera bene se mi sento come se
mi piace mi piace anche altro cioè
quello della descrizione si stia degli
ci vediamo non proseguirà da te lo dico
io il mio canale ma che voglio
[Musica]